[Music]
what's the nature of your objection mr
shellhorn
george i think there was a question
there
suggesting that the attack
the dog bite
and i think there was something else was
going on before any shots were fired
yeah i don't even know what that
i don't even know what the factual basis
is for that i can ask a witness no you
can't no you can't not without a factual
basis
you just can't ask for speculation
that's what you're asking for
a question whether or not there's no
evidence that it happened before
none
not not a cintilla i believe of evidence
on the record so far
so that that supports that question if a
witness says that something happened i
can't ask them
you've you've asked them
500 questions
about what happened about her
recollection of it which is fine now
you're asking well are you sure it
didn't happen before you have no basis
to ask that her recollection is horrible
no it's not she's changed her story over
and over it doesn't matter it doesn't mr
balinkas it does not allow you
to suggest to this jury to engage in
speculation which is what you're doing
your client doesn't remember the
incident
according to the expert reports
so that's not a factual basis for you
and there's nothing in this record to
suggest that any of this happened
the beating the phone the dog bite
before in fact we have a 9-1-1 call
where it's patently obvious
that the dog is in the area because it
is incessantly barking and heard over
the 9-1-1 call which is after the
shooting
so i
you need a factual basis that is black
letter law 101 my factual basis judge is
that these
people both cataract and goodwin
you know
have have a motive to lie with regards
to what happened
they they filed a lawsuit there's
hostility and
again even assuming all that's true
so there's no evidence no but there's no
evidence in the record that's like
saying well isn't it true that a
stranger drove down the road when
michael barrasson was there and got out
of his car and the stranger was the one
that actually shot you not mr barrison
that's the same situation there's no
evidence in the record that that
happened
you're just trying you you're trying to
create in the jury's mind some alternate
issue without any facts in the record to
support it now if mr barrisson we're
going to testify about something that's
different
but the experts have said he doesn't
remember anything about the incident i
understood judge but
again whatever ruling you you make
obviously i abide by it but in this
particular case
this witness's testimony as well as her
boyfriend which are basically the only
two pieces of evidence no and the 911
call
which lays out exactly what happened
immediately after the shooting
immediately after the shooting and i
believe i can question the timing of the
shooting based on their inconsistent
statement their motivation to lie
no you're not going to not not to create
some alternate universe scenario without
something in the record well i can't get
anything in the record judge unless i
could ask these questions no
there's plenty in the record so far
there's plenty in the record so far
but nothing in the record to show
that the beating the dog bite and
everything happened before the shooting
well mr goodwin is going to testify
judge the mrs cataract disappeared for a
significant point all right well then
ask him
ask him that question is impossible for
someone to be shot
mr blinkist
i can't predict what's going to go on on
the record in the future when other
witnesses testify if the scenario
changes then you can ask it then at this
point in time there's nothing in the
record
to suggest the scenario that you want to
ask in a question for the jurors there's
not
okay that's my ruling end of it
all right
go off the record now because you have
to uh
you